i bet i could answer this for you but
who is your favorite song
[Laughter]
[Music]
what are you on today that's fine what
do you want today uh and nothing what do
you want today live
h2o goodbye good vibes and a drink are
we recording yes are we recording right
now recording oh oh damn are we really
are we really
oh i saw that um that navarro team won
daytona this year they did mm-hmm yes
how do you feel about that
good good yeah yeah
you don't hold on to those rivals hell
no
i always felt so weird when people did
because i went to usc and people from
usc like at ufc you could buy a shirt
that says [ __ ] ucla on it yeah and that
rivalry is just too much that's too much
i don't have an attachment to any of
that and it's like i got to be attached
to something that means nothing to me
i'm not in the sport i'm not playing so
i don't really get attached to that's
why it's like hard for me to watch
sports
you have to get attached yeah i like
watching people talk [ __ ] i don't like
to be like a part of a team who talks
[ __ ] i want to be the third person like
thank you because i'm like is there
anyone that just genuinely
likes it it doesn't matter what team is
playing they just genuinely like to
[ __ ] watch it
right okay marky
you better stop playing
hella he's wearing a hell of a tight
shirt he's wearing a hella tight hella
tight like shortly flannel mark hello
all of the above we are recording though
yeah we're good to go well welcome back
to another episode of cats after dark
and more so welcome back nick because
he's back to life he's back live he's
back he's coherent he's aware he's alert
he knows what's going on all the only
thing in him today is white claw yeah
yeah well probably some food you
probably had some food uh oh yeah i had
a nice lorraine quiche from the cafe
down
can you tell us what happened after we
finished filming like what was your
process after the fact because chin
babies saw you for a little bit
shout out to the other people who said
send messages and like checked in on me
but i was actually concerned despite the
optics of those stories it was actually
the meatball story was my favorite was
meatballs yeah you're just sitting down
dude when you put your hands
and it looked like i was like struggling
but i was enjoying it because that was
like immediately after we finished and i
just wanted to go out and be in the sun
sit there and enjoy yeah that's why you
drove out you you was like
and the funniest thing is when i was
report uh recording that video i
actually had just gotten a text from
nick because i was supposed to take him
home he was like yeah i'm on the phone
i'm going to take a walk and just chill
and then i looked out the window and i
just saw him chilling
like if someone's on shrooms and does
that oh
but he was he was like are you sure
you're good i'm like i'm great i'm just
if you're on something else you're like
hey probably you shouldn't walk you
probably should sit down yeah that's why
after when i saw the video i thought
like he was having a bad trip because he
seemed happy and then he started rubbing
his face as a ghost
he would do shrooms he was just going to
walk yeah that's fine i just met him
like yeah come on what i said i just
meant in the video not i love walks you
like walks yes
during the pandemic oh oh everyone's
catching me on a [ __ ] hot walk
remember they tried telling us that we
couldn't go outside and walk isn't that
crazy who's gonna tell me who's gonna
tell me i can't walk
they try to like [ __ ] the wasn't it a
is are you saying they cause that's
their pronouns what nothing oh
yeah a little yeah dark area but i
remember when everyone was taking a walk
that app pokemon go got popular again
because people were walking around like
doing the
little um getting the little prizes
there were a lot of animal shelters who
allowed people to borrow dogs in the
shelters to get walked there which was
great yeah [ __ ] crazy yo so i was in
salt lake city how was that over the
weekend it was great
let me tell you
i met
a throuple
[ __ ] a guy two girls right guy
and two girls what was interesting about
this throuple you know what ruffle is
meatball yeah what is it it's when a guy
a guy or a girl has two significant
others gosh you're so smart so
this [ __ ] uh
the interesting part he's asian that's
the interesting word he was not asian
this dude and lady they had been
together they've been married for 28
years
wow right insane they were in mexico
met a girl mm-hmm added her alone i feel
like that happens a lot with people who
have been married for a while that's the
way they kind of spice it up yeah like
it's like you have to and i think you
have to sorry sorry
i did i said that those words come out
of my mouth
no i i think no you have to spice it up
i'm not saying you you have to spice it
up that way yeah yeah some people like
to do it different ways some
[ __ ] want to trouble some
[ __ ] just want to go on a trip
you know what i'm saying so that was the
crazy part was like so she had been
together with them for like two years
and they're all married i've never seen
it where they're all married
what do you mean they're all married
like all three they are together
oh that's cute yeah i like that i feel
like that's a
that's a cool situation if all of them
are in an equally
like committed relationship especially i
think that works out really well if the
girl is bisexual as well so it's kind of
like yes i feel like that then takes
like checks off all the boxes for
everyone involved yep and i feel like
the the wife
okay the og
og wife
is the leader of the [ __ ] pack
oh i love that she's the i feel like
she's the dominant i do feel like in a
lot of those cases the
if the females are not the one in charge
it then is always it almost feels like
it's gotta be weird she's following what
her like guy wants but she doesn't
really want that and that's a wrong
assumption to have but that's just how i
feel see that's what i'm saying like if
a guy is dominant in a throuple yeah
it's probably like one of one of the
[ __ ] is leaving yeah but if but
if the girl is dominant
what happened uh
but if the girl is um
the dominant one the dominant one i feel
like that's what makes it work yeah
because i agree because the girl is like
i like this dude and i like this girl
boom yeah cause and i figured she was
the dominant one because she was doing
all the talking
yeah you know what i mean i get that
which is funny because then she's
probably submissive what'd you say in
bed she's probably submissive because
she's the dominant one like as a friend
i i feel like people who usually already
know some [ __ ]
[ __ ] you did a threesome no no okay i'm
listening because the cat's saying she's
probably submissive so she probably just
lets him do whatever i feel like
yeah i feel like a lot of uh dominant
people both men and women if you're
dominant in your everyday life sexually
you're usually more dominant like
submissive yes submissive i mean yeah
that means like you like hey do it all
right yeah you kind of like give up
power like i don't want to have to think
about
that's it because i hear so many stories
about these high like pow like men in
high power positions where like maybe a
ceo or runs their own company where in
bed they want a girl who's more
aggressive who's more dominant
i feel like yeah yeah i feel like they
want to get picked i feel like in 2022
the woman has to be the dominant one for
the throttle for the throttle
dude because the dude like
got a lot of different motives and [ __ ]
it's like hey let's have a tropo you
know so eventually i'll leave your ass
and just end up with this girl that i
really want you know what i mean because
that [ __ ] happens that [ __ ] happens it
absolutely can happen and i think that
happens more often than not in truffles
unfortunately i know but maybe they
haven't figured it out but they i think
they haven't figured out because they
they were because they weren't like
weird about it and they they were like
yeah this is our [ __ ] life yeah you
know i mean we're just so [ __ ] yeah
but it's kind of like it like they just
accepted it yeah you know did you do you
know their info could we talk to them oh
yeah that'd be awesome
that would be awesome oh [ __ ]
that if you're watching this yeah yeah
if you're the police creature at the
shows in salt lake city i want to say it
was the
second show it's going to be like
12 different groups
if we don't find them
like if there's any trouble out there
yeah that's so interesting that's
willing to talk about it because there's
so many [ __ ]
you know there's a lot of questions and
there's it's
i don't know i feel like there's a way
that that has to work and
for them it probably does [ __ ] work
and they were all good-looking like
literally every single person the guy
and the two girls they were all like
good-looking people yeah
i would have assumed
no i would always assume there's a run
there's always a rush yeah yeah he's
always a runner
there's a run that you use the word
right i know come on there's a run to
the group it's like [ __ ] dogs
yeah of the litter
come on you never seen a run there's
always i listen i've seen another
throughput at a show before
right that was when i was in florida and
then
and uh what'd you say shocking
[Laughter]
if it's not utah then it's then it's
florida yeah yeah but like
they were all like one of one person was
hot and one it was one girl
wrestling [ __ ] runs
so long and you're talking about the
entire state of florida
hey i love florida i go there yeah
please buy my tickets next time in
florida i can't too there's plenty of
good-looking people anywhere there's sun
there's good-looking people yeah right
um but they were all busted and they
were kind of loud about it and the girls
were like making out dudes i said yeah
yeah they might as well said that you
know what i mean and i'm sitting here
i'm like why is she with them what the
[ __ ] is it maybe ugly people like get
down to bed really good
i don't know also
it could be just what she's attracted to
ugly maybe because on my for you page on
tick tock it's just a bunch of like
really beautiful like bisexual women
with like and they keep saying i l my
type of woman is like beautiful ethereal
women and then my type in men is like
medium ugly guys like can we still call
people ugly as well
right i think so
i think so yeah and also like when you
when you say you're ugly that's not bad
it's not a bad thing i i do think he's
not bad yeah bubba sparks ugly
shout out to brian callan for being that
musical music video
yeah he was a salesman in the bubba
sparks
uh from the wrong angle with my mouth up
and i can be real ugly i think everyone
is ugly about it there's an ugly side of
me bro my turn to my [ __ ] whatever
the way this is
define you as a person you know when i'm
real ugly people take pictures of me
like this
oh my god like i'm up am i and i'm
elevated if you take a picture of me
like i'm
this i go first of all who [ __ ] likes
to take a picture like that what is this
dude i'm not the sun i'm not the sky
yeah right you need that myspace and
like the high up you're looking like
give me that [ __ ] angle bro your chin
is looking up your double chin is hidden
these [ __ ] people goddamn
shitty ass photography work
what are you looking for i think it's
just uh the buffalo blocker
i had it but then it was like starting
to screw with all my others
right now there he is why is that the
funniest [ __ ] i've ever seen that has to
be a wiggler right no that's bryan's no
that's no that's not his like
no one's here that's not that's a toupee
that's brian's hair don't do that no
y'all be i think bubba sparks is so cute
oh you find bubba smith yeah like
especially when he's chubby i don't know
what it is like i like kind of chubby
men they have their youtube channels we
can't say like
ugly's not a [ __ ] thing you know
chubby's not a [ __ ] thing you know
whatever who cares who cares right right
or am i tripping i think i think you
just got to embrace whatever you're
working with and what was that then you
could be attractive like that that's
boba sparks no i think he lost a bunch
of a bunch of weights
yeah i feel like he got skinny recently
yeah go to his sister [ __ ]
wait did you guys hear about this what
was isn't that old
what year is that
oh 2009. yeah get out of here
go to bubble sparks instagram
he's probably killing it
he probably smells like wings and [ __ ]
now yeah
i think
him being arrested
or mad lib gosh
look at christian looking extra [ __ ]
arrogant in that picture
let him live
look at him wow that's a good picture
you look great
see i tried to tear them down y'all just
lifted them up whatever anyways go to
bar with sparks
oh sorry i think this is uh before we
started uh i the picture reminded me uh
the blurry cameras last week yeah
everybody was like oh so i just wanted
people to see what i saw yeah
is there anything wrong not easy yeah it
was like a pov episode oh no he looks
great he looks like he yeah yeah he
looks healthy
good for him yeah he's killing it he's
kind of fired i think he does jewelry
now right i thought of something with
wings
that hoodie is really fire i actually
really like that his sweater
who does he look like i'm like i can't
put my
i can't put my tongue on it he looks
like someone like a famous actor but i
can't think of who i don't know a famous
actor
i don't know
yeah i wonder what yeah he does
something
he does something like he has something
in food or something right it's nice to
see the evolution of these like people
these stars like they have another one
uh uh rick ross
rick ross is a mogul he's a yeah he's a
mogul i want you to talk about the
evolution of their like
community
and [ __ ] oh no no i meant like evolution
of like their career path went from
oh yeah i was worried i'd be seeing
these people and they still kind of do
but like rap until they're like 55 60
and you're like that's weird but they've
a lot of them have been able to
translate when you think about it like
you can't i mean you'll make money as a
rapper and you'll probably make like
really good money but like
there's more there's more to life than
just that
and most of the time the money comes
from performing which means you got to
be there but you want mailbox money you
want to not have to perform yeah the
fact that you don't have to leave your
house and you just make the money oh god
rick ross i think has a trademark for
lemon pepper chicken yeah does he yeah
did he like invent that
claiming he uh created the burrito he
did yeah he did it
huh say something different he he did
create i'm pretty sure he also shot an
18
golf course
yeah whole 18 holes and he probably did
do you think that people actually look
the people do you think is people
actually believe him or no
i think they have no choice
but
when you're in the privacy of your own
home and everything dude like and kim
jong-un comes on the tv and says oh yeah
i made the burrito do you think the
citizens are like yeah that's something
if that's all they can see though
because
yeah because they're probably living
they control what they watch that's why
i want to know it's like it's an
interesting thought experiment yeah and
if none of them have golf before and
don't know what golfing i didn't know
what 18 was
none of them know
like have ever seen a burrito let alone
a mexican restaurant are they allowed to
like
live
no
it looks terrible man yeah yeah it looks
terrible wow
would you visit if you could and come
back no i'd be a prisoner no no i'm
saying like they said they said like
like
sir like say you you have a 100
guarantee of going there and back like
you will come back and you will get
kidnapped would you go and visit this
kid i wouldn't believe it first of all
but i would be intrigued you know so
when i went to korea with my parents we
went there twice we went to the dmz
which is a demilitarized zone yeah
that's like the border of south korea
north korea so they let you walk around
there's like a little the second worst
dm something
there was a line there too but wartime
is worse than being at the dmv what's
the point of the joke
yeah sorry
there's like a little i don't know it's
like a regular like it looks like a
miniature house where it's like a
meeting area for korea south korea and
north korea so basically half the table
is in the north korean side half the
tables in south korea so then they let
you walk at when you visit there they
let you walk around to the north korean
side but they're saying like we're just
letting you know
something could happen potentially like
they could actually come in and grab you
or whatever but yeah we'd likely want
that though
like 60 minutes or something too isn't
there like 400 yards or something of
like neutral ground at points in between
i don't know about neutral ground uh but
like yeah they were like soldiers
people are pointing weapons yeah if you
would walk there which one did you go in
like what building it was like whether
the tourist one oh okay i'm not sure
which one was but was one of them you
know if your heart's beating to you when
you walk across you're like yeah
how old were you when you went
early twenties okay wow i didn't
appreciate i didn't watch korean dramas
or korean shows at that time yeah so i
was like oh gotta go here and then i had
an argument with my girlfriend at the
time so i'm like oh i want to be bad
cause it's like you know i'm upset yeah
now i'm like oh my god i wish i just
enjoyed all the beautiful things in
korea yeah
that's so crazy
wait click that picture of the fourth
picture in the top right this one yeah
what's going on oh are we supposed to
open with that segment of
recommendations i just want to do it at
some point before the very end of the
episode chad recommends
korea
yeah
it's a fun tour yeah i recommend that
and we're not
we're not supposed to do anything i i
just you know confusing stuff to give us
stuff to talk about you know i would
love any ideas from from the crowd i
don't want to be like we have to do this
i want us all to come hang out have a
great time yeah he does man
wait so what is this building
the dmt theater
i have no idea i wasn't asking you
you can't see it i'm trying
[Music]
i
do you have something you're excited to
recommend kat
uh yeah recently i've actually been
watching a lot of this youtube channel
called weird history i really like
learning random things about history but
i get bored reading like i just feel
like a lot of books that i've found for
things that i want to learn more about
is very boring i have to learn a very
specific way yeah and this channel just
shows me so many random things like i
learned about uh the chinese uh foot
binding uh method which i was talking to
you about earlier today and that shit's
[ __ ] crazy i didn't mean a strong
point but yeah strong point because it's
crazy it's absolutely insane they're
breaking these little girls like toes
from
the age of four in order to mold them
into tiny shoes they're wrapping their
feet up to look like a hoof
and they do this
until they're married and then women are
allowed to like take it off but it's
just as painful to get your feet back to
normal at that point than it is to like
keep it there and some women keep it
their entire lives because the thought
was that one small feat was the
idealized version of beauty idea of
beauty in china back in the day and they
also had this assumption that since your
feet are now like hooves you have to
rely more on your thigh muscles which
then means you're probably probably good
in bed
cool so like that's wild and that's the
[ __ ] that is
great i love it it's not fake tits yeah
it's small feet wow solid logic i've
seen uh center stage what what's center
screen what's up it's the uh it's about
ballerinas and it's like it shows them
like hardcore at like their academy and
[ __ ] and they [ __ ] up their feet really
bad but they all have extremely
strong thighs meatball pull up their
feet oh ballerina feet are insane
and feet biting
feet binding yeah ballerina feet and
feet binding bro and i was learning
about cleopatra too apparently she
wasn't egyptian she was actually greek
i did not know that yeah i learned a lot
of people's stuff on that youtube
channel
isn't that insane look at that look at
the toes
this just like
uh blew my mind recently and i i still
don't even know the answer but when
would you guys think don't answer cat
cause you just watched a video on it
what year
cleopatra lived
or like years cleopatra yeah
well wasn't she cleopatra
no she's a real person but she did
associate herself with the god within
egyptian mythology
1909.
i'm waiting for everybody else's answer
and not trying to give a reaction but
that's not it
it wasn't like 1900 i thought i was just
in literature too like
who wants to go next 1780
i'd say
15 23 like 15. i would have said i would
have said like
100
100 you know like bc ad either one
around like the start but it was like
pretty recent you guys were all recent i
don't remember my point exactly
i don't know
the reason why the reason 69 bc no
cleopatra the seventh there were several
cleopatras during the seven uh rule but
the the popular one is the seven right
yeah this one oh okay wait man my entire
maybe i thought i was like i'm thinking
of something else too because the
pyramids aren't actually that old yeah
maybe it was the pyramids that aren't
there because the pyramids were uh built
not too long ago
in comparison to like when all the like
mummy stuff was happening maybe that's
what there's a big gap from like the
pharaoh's time to like
what 200. what are my thousands
yes we're having a mandela effect but
also like i'm watching youtube videos
for facts so take that with a grain of
salt i didn't know that it was like i
thought cleopatra was old but i didn't
know she was that old
think about being born in 69 that's it
no 19. not 1969. 69.
it's a good i mean i don't know if they
were doing it like that back then
and you think they were doing 69s in bc
i think it's like i don't know it's just
one of those things like i i don't think
it's that far
no that was discovered earlier
yeah think about it like a lot of sex
stuff was probably discovered super
[ __ ] early yeah i mean right you guys
think about it yeah you weren't just
doing missionary they were exploring
because look at the comments
who the karma sutra the uh indian book
about sex what about it uh it shows you
all these different positions to have
sex to reach orgasm it's like way back
in the day really like yeah what year is
the kama kamasutra christian
christian kamasutra kamasu i don't even
know how to spell that
that's what you give we're dropping out
of community college
it's fine i went to a normal college i
still can't spell it well figure it out
and i put sutra i think you're thinking
phonetically
yeah well but you use phonics to speak
phonetically i'm hooked on five what
does it say
come on dude i have a really
huge problem with phonics
back in the day when they try to sell
ebonics to people
no
the top the top left is how you spell
that was a real thing
they would i remember hooked on fox yeah
there was a different version of that
where people were trying to show
americans how to speak like in an urban
way
learn how to speak on ebonics i've heard
of ebonics yeah i i didn't know there
was like a like a program an infomercial
yeah yeah so what do we want to see
about this book that sounds like an snl
sketch what was this oh when did it come
out or when did comments when was
kamasutra invented or yeah
when did the book come out
written
that's fair that's [ __ ] fair that's
fair okay anyone says that's fair
that's
somewhere when you were looking it up it
said it was written in english in like
the 1800s look at this there's no way
okay meatball so here we go yeah scroll
uh
it they don't have like the creation
date in its native language so 400 bc is
when they was telling you how to get
dirty yeah that's what we're like
yeah
yeah i guarantee they were doing that i
feel like anal was probably one of the
first how they wrote it
because of sodom and gomorrah
what is that it were these two cities
these biblical old testament cities and
they like partied all the time and they
were like anal so god smited them i
can't i don't know
yeah but
i think gamora they were good and
possibly saved
uh interest samora they were [ __ ]
each other in the ass and things yeah so
women some women were
stuck in dingle leagues back in the day
oh absolutely i think so and dudes were
already you know doing the
i think dudes were sucking dinglings
back in the days yeah everything you
heard of uh
you guys love ryan holiday right yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
exactly what was seneca whatever they
said that the stuff that we're doing now
happened two thousand years ago it's
basically the same stuff it's just we
we're doing it in this time it is time
frame it's the same
[ __ ] things are crazy and i go they
always been yeah yeah they've always
been [ __ ] crazy that's why whenever
like not saying that
not to disrespect anyone that feels this
way but it's like when people say oh i
don't want kids because i don't want to
bring a kid into this crazy world yeah
and meanwhile i'm like
world's always been crazy you're having
a great [ __ ] time here that's all
people always say that [ __ ] i go what
[ __ ] you having the time of your
[ __ ] life maybe they want to keep it
that way though and i would say but just
say that but people always like blame it
on like i don't want to be bring a kid
into this crazy world what yeah
and i feel like if you're a good person
you have like a responsibility to bring
a kid
yeah exactly i disagree huh i disagree
oh my god please tell me you seem very
passionate about this
oh i don't mean responsibility but i i
think it is obligated if you want a kid
for sure yeah yeah yeah yeah if you want
a kid that you should feel that
responsibility yeah but if you don't
have the means if you're not like yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah then i would say
probably don't do it if you can't take
care of that kid though yeah if you
can't take care of it yeah then probably
yeah just just and people that say
listen when people say that [ __ ] i i
don't want you to go have a kid because
then you're doing it out of there
there's no authenticity to it you're
just walking around children be
authentic yeah be authentic with having
a [ __ ] child yeah punk [ __ ]
sorry and also uh not you chin about
things not being as bad there's this
harvard professor named steven steven
bigger tin right fingers in order no
speaker i think he's been named on um
epstein's man of uh flight management oh
no he hasn't uh but we that doesn't it's
like michael jackson i still like man in
the mirror
the guys uh academic journals or
whatever better better angels of our
nature yeah mortality rate wars
every single measure dude the type of
violence back in the day
we we do not have that kind of violence
like the way they would just [ __ ]
kill a person back in the day like with
the kings and queens and that [ __ ] and
that and the way they used to do the way
they used to do it was insane insane
dude
they don't do it like that no more
mm-hmm
um and uh before we get to the rest of
our recommendations last week
meatball's recommendation was his uh
dad's
new company sky
pack
and uh we did uh we kind of [ __ ] on it i
kind of i kind of [ __ ] on it yeah uh but
did i sit on it no
we didn't get a great explanation of
what it actually was so i wanted to uh
talk to meatballs dad talk about skypath
security and just learn maybe a little
bit more about meatball and gianni i
wonder if i was closer with my
on what i thought about what your guess
was we're like
a detector i hope yeah i hope i'm right
we can also ask about our respective
inventions yeah yeah
go over there that's a good person yep
a good person yeah that's how we figure
it out it's like who's a good person
i also know why i just want to know
who's gonna be in charge of writing the
guidebook of like what good is
considered and what that is
yeah yeah
it's gotta be a regular person right
it's gonna be a good person who's a good
who's a good person you feel like you
would trust yeah
to test the bullet yeah oh no no no no
like right you'd be fine no you're like
you're good
because obviously there has to be a
there has to be a guy
oh i guess you're only good if it
no because there has works be a guide
yeah whoa look where they're at oh damn
where they are oh they're all official
super official
what's up how are we doing
how are you doing he's a little slow
no it's not meatball small no it's not
he hasn't really put in the effort to
learn and troubleshoot on his own but
he's doing a good job with what i've
showed him
he does really well when you tell him to
do something
now we got to work on like him going out
of his way today yeah yeah i think
that's what i don't know on his own how
to do that and that's the audio hey like
that's youtube uh meatball on youtube
youtube but what do i google audio
issues when we're trying to signal flow
signal signal okay hey single flow yeah
see you got it or i will show you
everything you need to know you're just
not allowed to have your phone in here
that's fine
just tell brenda not to blow me up
everything yeah that's true meatball
that is true that is fair that is fair
yeah how are you doing mr paolo
paolo
i am doing fantastic is paulo
oh i love that sweatshirt that guy's
wearing that nice yes nice thank you for
it i'm trying to make it my life's goal
to only wear free merch and this is some
of the best i've ever seen
we don't play
so we uh yeah christian brought up
your company we didn't really let him
finish the explanation so we wanted to
give you a chance to hear from the
horse's mouth what does it actually do
how are we stopping these these school
shootings basically christian wasn't a
great representation of the company
it's kind of hard to explain someone
explain it to someone when someone's
tripping balls on troops
that's fair we
i heard the story about the shrooms last
week
it was good for numbers which means you
got more impressions
great so i'll just wait so my name is
david pale i'm the ceo of skype
christian is my son this is derek work
he is a former uh
uh captain of the rhode island state
police 20 28 years of service there uh
he's now our chief threat assessment
officer here so what what uh i know it's
gonna show up in time so i'll be quick
on on the tech piece i won't be too
typical so what our technology does is
we've taken
typically what it what people do as a
threat assessment uh and the way it's
done now it's all done by paper so they
do blueprints they do a walkthrough they
write in the blueprints they create a
paper report they give a paper report
back to the client and the client either
fixes the mitigates the problems or not
there's no incentive to do so and then
that data ends up in a filing cabinet
somewhere so what we did was we took
that that fragmented piece and we
created a platform for it where it's all
done electronically individually so they
now upload their blueprints to uh or
schematics to our platform if they don't
have any we have a tool where they can
use their camera and we'll auto render
the blueprints for them for us for our
guys to look at
once that happens derek's team gets it
uh he assigns a threat assessment
officer he'll review it and then once
they answer the questions um he'll the
threat assessment officer will then look
at the blueprints he'll pin right to
them where he would like to see photos
or videos of once he has all that data
he'll then create his report by actually
pinning the the vulnerabilities on this
so he might kind of say hey there's a uh
a broken door here or i'd like to see uh
cement pylons in the front of this he
would put all the vulnerabilities there
and then they're incentivized to fix
them because once they
mitigate a certain percentage whether it
be 70 80 or 90 of it um they will get
certified by us so they'll get a
certificate that they're threat
certified they can use that certificate
to get um
uh discounts on their property accounts
insurance so there's kind of a center
for that and then we send them out these
blue stickers to put on their their
windows just like an adt alarm sticker
as we become the industry standard
people will look at that sticker and say
hey that's a safer place to shop a safer
place to dine a safer place to have my
podcast
[Music]
hey that place is protected maybe i'll
find another place to move on to um and
that's the threat assessment piece then
here's where the the real interesting
partnership then we take that data that
we now have it's also digitized and we
link it up directly to first responders
so now as is we'll use a school shooting
for a school isn't it so if there's a
school shooting
as the school shooting kick that
teachers in the school activate the the
uh the app
as police are rolling they will pull up
on their on their
in-dash in-car laptops their mobile
devices um dispatch on their computer
they'll pull up the live schematics of
the building so they'll see to scale
everything that they have there so uh
elevations so you don't see points of
elevations places to cover places to
hide they'll have all the information
and the accurate layout of the facility
and then the teachers on the inside now
they're also interacting so typically um
our law enforcement guys here the
teachers don't like to hide in their
classrooms because they're afraid no
one's even know where they are so they
tend to run out and get themselves in
more trouble or get themselves killed
with our app they'll be able to push one
button on their phone lock the door take
the kids to put them in a safe place
they're gonna push one bucket on their
phone and as police are rolling the
schematic coming up those rooms are
gonna turn reds if they're in and
they're gonna put in the they're a bunch
of the room number you're gonna put in
the number of people there in a code
word so now as again they're rolling the
schematics come up all rooms where
people that people they need to evacuate
are are hiding are listed on there so
they'll go to the door they'll bang on
the door they'll say rhode island state
police uh your code word is eraser sure
that teacher hears that word she'll
bring the kids to the door the police
will escort them to safety and as they
do they'll radio into dispatch that that
room 212 is clear and dispatch will turn
that room from red to green and then
they'll go to all the red rooms first
turn them to green
and check them where it takes a lot more
time took over the door police call
police car wait and then turn all those
room between until the entire building
is clear
now if there are cameras in the building
like if there are cameras in the
building they'll be able to link
directly to the cameras from there
outside from their devices but our team
here will also be able to see on this
screen that we're working on right now
what's going on in the school so as
police are rolling again they're getting
into schematics they're getting the
rooms where everybody all the people
that need to evacuate are and then
our guys they'll be getting text
messages at the bottom of the screen
from our guys here okay we see two
offenders um identify hardware once
carrying an ar-15 with a backpack with
extra magazines the other guy's carrying
a handgun we can't identify the caliber
this is what they're wearing and this is
where they're located right now so all
of that gator is key because as they get
there the more the quicker it allows
them to
alleviate the situation quicker and save
lives and save property
i was just gonna say i would like i
would like christian
yeah christian in
30 seconds
say what your dad's company yeah yeah
how can you go christian i'll get it
i'll get a chance you simply
you know there's something special
though so when we just so it costs a
little bit of money for schools to put
something so when we design this
we wanted it was it was uh really our
permission to say hey we want to decide
something that could not protect schools
protect public buildings protect people
everywhere and it's for all hazards it's
not just shootings it's for fire medical
abroad progressive situations will
handle all of those things but we wanted
to make this
available to everybody not just the
people that can afford it and we weren't
going to build something unless we could
find a way to everybody be able to get
this technology
or not so what we did was we we launched
a separate entity called the sky token
foundation it's a cryptocurrency that
currently trades called sky also sky the
sky token foundation and what that that
specifically is it's a delaware
non-profit that
when people buy the token okay and it's
trading right now i think it's trading
somewhere around a dollar 18 a token
right now but people buy the token not
only is it a direct write-off because
it's a 501 3c nonprofit all of the money
that's raised for that goes to
underprivileged schools and
municipalities that can't afford our
technology for us to be able to put it
into those locations so everybody can
can get the benefit of this technology
not just the people that can afford it
have you already started talking to like
governments uh local governments and
stuff about getting it because
government contracts that's when you get
the real money
yeah so the state of the state of
florida passed the law
uh early last year that every school in
the state of florida is required to have
our technology by a certain thing uh
they think
it's included they listed the law
yeah
good question and good good question
i'll take your questions
but so so would it be accurate to say
that sky path security
simplifies communication between
occupants
in an emergency and the authorities and
first responders yeah who are helping
facilitate the rescue
yes absolutely so second matter right so
as a first responder when i go to a
facility that i've never been into
before
it shows me a map of how i need to get
there where the threat is immediately
and get there as quick as possible
because our job is to neutralize that
threat so it is something that's not out
there it doesn't exist with this
real-time communication involved in law
enforcement or fire and the people
involved in that incident so it's a
state-of-the-art technology that we have
right now i bet you wish you would have
had it in the departed huh
the departed
the accident was incredible
leave it up to nick
i'm trying to keep it light that's a lot
of information flying it is a lot of
information but it's actually [ __ ]
time after all that you're not tired
uh so do you think being a tick tock
superstar has helped or hurt your
company's success
well that depends uh on who is uh tick
tock about whether it's johnny's or
meatballs
i've just heard that you've gotten
recognized on the street for some of the
tick tocks that your sons have put up
so dad was yelling at you earlier about
eating this candy bar
home depot or at a retail store and i
present my credit card they look at it
and they go are you chinese dad yeah
uh and i bet i could answer this for you
but who's your favorite son
look at the hoodie
[Laughter]
it hard today he wore it all day all day
today
well fellas uh
uh thanks for talking to us again yeah
thank you that was awesome vicious and
worthwhile endeavor and we wish you all
the best of luck i know i hope this
[ __ ] blows up i'm gonna buy some sky
definitely so right now it's going crazy
as far as what what we've got the
candidates of uh some provinces and
candidates that want to put 150 schools
on so that's going very very well as far
as us the pipeline of getting things
going what we really want to do is we
really want to get this the uh the token
the the the sky foundation
crypto piece really kind of moving so
that'll help us be able to do places
that can't afford it which is what
really what our mission is we want to
those places are more susceptible to
things like that and we want to make
sure that they'll put that in for them
and everybody's got a chance
to go to our website click on a form a
great form fill it out it goes to the
foundation and the foundation approves
it pays us and then we go put it in for
free for them that's awesome that's
amazing so you can't go on shark tank
we're we're well beyond shot jack oh
damn
what are you saying he's well beyond
shark tank
cuban can't help it he's got it but if
you can get on there you just use it as
a as a commercial that's what most
people do
a lot of people do that the guys that
don't take the deals and walk away
usually i tell them to [ __ ] off it'd go
viral
[Laughter]
because
you know the show's been on for 10 12
years and a guy will go down there and
completely go down in flames like
haven't you watched the show they asked
to say i know
i don't know how could you not know
what's two shows you know
yo your dad's funny dog i think your
dad's the funniest one in the family
he's the funniest one in the family
dude do not say that because now i'm
going to be hearing about this for the
next six months
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
thanks guys wait hang on before i go i
want to ask you guys what you guys think
yeah
what celebrity do you think my father
looks like he gets mistaken for all the
time and i want to see if you guys can
catch it what
i see it yes i see it you already told
me the answer so i won't say all right
where's brendan when you need him he's
good at that [ __ ] brandon would not get
it
he's well he's a king of [ __ ] true
all right mommy just said yeah yeah
shoot mcgavin i don't know who is that
yeah christopher parker have you guys
seen you haven't seen happy gilmore have
you seen happy gilmore i might oh [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah the guy goes shoot up
yeah yeah yeah he's like he's like his
nemesis yeah literally everywhere like
he'll literally get recognized like holy
[ __ ] it's shooter that's so
yo
wow
mistakenly tmz mistake me once yeah i
was you know
i was in i was uh
having some business meetings i was dr i
was in a limo like a suburban and i was
rolling up to mr ciao which is you know
tmz was there they started running along
the side of the car taking pictures so
i'm getting out of the car i'm laughing
i don't know what the [ __ ] going on
and the the driver gets out of the car
he puts his arm around the guy that goes
who do you think that is he was that's
christopher mcdonald chris mcdonough now
that's some [ __ ] technology getting
around he's nobody
and the guy was spacious enough he sent
me all the pictures of the role of but
the driver going up from like it was
like he was blocking the camera and
everything was
that's [ __ ] hilarious
pieces of [ __ ] for breakfast
that's that quote from happy gilmore for
anybody
[Laughter]
uh well thanks guys uh
so
how people can help by going to uh where
what yeah where can people help to go
if they go to the
uh look up as a cryptocurrency sky which
is the sky token foundation they'll find
it there or they can go to our website
at skypath.com and they can see
everything there and there's some links
there that'll bring them to where they
need to go that's awesome awesome
anybody funny on the air i'm available
yeah yeah
thanks fellas thank you guys thanks guys
thank you see you guys all right see you
bye now the awkward hang up part yeah i
know yeah because it always stalls oh
it's not awkward i just press a button
[Laughter]
christian i your dad truly is the star
of you yeah he's the star he's the star
he's the main character he's the star of
the family i'm so excited to break
that's why you're tick tock ain't
blowing up it's your father
if your dad had a tick tock bruh he
would [ __ ] you do you want to see a sick
dog he should just tighten up that
elevator pitch i will say i mean it was
yeah i know
i love them like i i looked around the
entire room and i was like damn does
anyone know what he's saying right now
or i did yeah but like it was just so
long i was like i kind of like
hey you know you're the same way i'm i'm
glad you know i know but we're people on
a podcast they're like i mean now it's
an infomercial yeah give us a beat i
think you're also really good at
elevator pitches i think a lot of people
try to explain themselves to get every
detail because they're afraid like oh
i'm gonna miss something out you're
really good at being like what do you
absolutely need to know and what's going
to hook you when you gave that very much
later i i i need your add-ons no
i love hyping people up i hype you up i
hyped kyle up it's my favorite she had
man she said i was looking slimmer you
do your face look slimmer i said that
the other day too them hikes
did you say that the other day yeah at
the gym
you're like do i look skinny i was like
yeah you i was like you look uh skinny
on your face like really really yeah
like exactly like that that's where i
lose weight my face yeah it's better i
mean look at patty the battery he gains
all of his weight oh yeah
today he texted he was like oh yeah i do
want to watch a couple of those uh
meatballs uh dad's tick tock today paddy
the baddie tweeted out he was like uh
anybody know where to watch the
liverpool game in san diego uh
he's here
yeah i don't know why when someone was
like oh it's a small group of of us
we're a fan club it'll probably only be
a handful since it's a weekday and he's
like i'll see you in an hour and i was
like [ __ ] you i wouldn't go i would be
down there if i like didn't have
something to do today uh yeah he went
you just watched the game oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] scousers they love their they
love their scouser
i do hear it here too
i mean san diego so i don't know yes
india isn't too far yeah true it is a
hike but it's not i don't want to reach
out
into the mic
oh i didn't want to eat candy
yeah act like i won't reach out
do it
i'm sure he's got to be here for a while
i didn't know he's in town either but
yeah he tweeted dude you know
that'd be great let's reach out to him i
mean let's reach out to him let's do it
seriously i gotta message them right now
actually
you won't group chat jack shore patty
and chappelle oh my god yeah
and you name it i want manchester united
no you can't yeah well they well they're
not from manchester they'll probably be
mad at that one oh yeah oasis then yeah
i'll name it oasis oasis yeah that'd be
what'd you say word nica uh he went to
go peepee oh okay
you see what my brother just texted all
of us because he saw my story
he said how much of a rollercoaster is
my father
which one which brother tank
i would tank how would tank text you i
don't know think about that tank is my
number
how because he messaged me when we after
we talked that day
oh yeah who's like if you ever want to
hang out [ __ ] [ __ ] here's my number
no we did not all right yeah well also
they're like boys
tank is not boys with no offense nothing
personal against chappelle but we
already talked about why
leave tank alone
no cat calls him big mac yeah i call him
big maggot
but he's tall he's the tallest right
huh tank your brother tank
he's got
he's probably gonna hate me doing this
are all of your brother short kings yeah
i think gianni might be the tallest
which is sad
yeah but at the same time i feel like as
if you're short that's fine if you give
off short energy that's where the issue
is because it gives off napoleon complex
there's absolutely nothing wrong with
being a shortened hand there's
everything wrong with
like how you know your brothers you know
your brother's hygienist no i don't i
really it's shadow band oh shadow man
what's so funny about accounts being
shadow band yeah there are
okay so there's this girl i follow on
instagram who um
she
wants to make she used to [ __ ] on people
for making only fans a while ago it's
kind of like okay if that's your opinion
that's your opinion that's fine but
she's on uh cameo doing the exact same
[ __ ] in like lingerie like
so i'm like i don't see why you have an
issue like you're like shooting other
girls for doing only fans when like you
do this but recently she started to talk
about how her accounts shadow banned
because she's posting like product
product um no i can't
work from knockout thank you oh my god
those words had a [ __ ] chokehold on
me yeah she's posting provocative photos
which is fine
and she's saying that she's being shadow
banned from instagram if she wants to
start and only fans to post the photos
where like she can't post on there she's
like it's my natural body and i should
be able to post it as i want like i
don't see how this is obscene this is
the natural female form yeah but her
account is a shadow band cause you could
look her up yeah so she's just like
trying to hype herself to get to like
almost be like oh it's okay if i have an
only fan so because like i'm not doing
like the same thing those girls are
doing but we all know it's a cash grab
yeah
listen i thought i was shadow band for a
second really why i don't know there was
something weird like what happened with
your account when i was saying anything
it was just like something like that
happened wasn't much happening and then
someone uh asked me what my instagram
was and i went to type it in
and literally like
usually when i get to s-h-a-p
yeah like it pops up immediately yeah
but i had to write out my full really
yeah i wonder what i did
do you know when it was there was a
while away i remember like santino's
saying he was shadow band for like a
month ago yeah oh a month ago it's
recent then yeah it was super recent huh
that's interesting yeah i don't know
what i did i don't even post anything
crazy first of all i barely even [ __ ]
post
i just wanted to give uh people context
to why cat calls my older brother big
magga uh if you go to his instagram you
can kind of get the vibe
oh you guys shoot guns
yeah he's your real true sayer
oh my gosh
no that's halloween hated his face
that's been him every day since that
picture
i love it first of all who dresses up
like that for a halloween dog it was a
privilege for him
to do it bro during i'm not kidding
during like the riots and covenant and
everything he bought
a bulletproof vest
two guns and smoke grenades and his
reason was what
that's what we asked him and he said you
never know
that he legit thinks that there will be
comic there will come a time where he
will actually have to use his smoke
bombs and bulletproof okay kyle
renthouse that's hilarious though
i kind of see where your brother's
coming from because i used to hang out
with a bunch of guys who were into anime
who who were exactly the same but they
would collect swords like they would go
to anime conventions and buy like
katanas for the exact same reason like
someone breaks into my house
[Music]
in san jose and buy a katana so i kind
of get it that is funny
those are the guys i used to date yeah i
think i think going from your brother to
my recommendation is actually a pretty
good school would you recommend oh yeah
uh it's this twitter account it's at
crack connoisseur uh that the name is is
it but
no it's it's like a
crack like uh i have a link on that that
sheet you were just on
i think if you you can just click on
crack okay sure uh
it's like uh
god it's really hard to explain but he
puts out these videos it's kind of like
a
dipping no deep fake uh
there's funny things about it but it's
like dipping your toe into uh conspiracy
theories but it helps if you like
hip-hop he just puts together these
awesome edits that'll illustrate a story
uh
and then they set it to hip hip hop go
to go to video one on the on the run
down
oh and run down
[Music]
so this one
is
is furthering the conspiracy that
justin trudeau is
uh
what's his name fidel castro's uh son
start from the beginning
what are the happy memories the ones
that transcended
it's both sorry i didn't mean is that
justin trudeau's mom right yes
i know she's pretty she was like an
author and model
i mean you don't think she's pretty you
don't think she's pretty okay this
freeze frame probably not no i mean like
when he was playing earlier remember
everyone has ugly angles yeah hey
remember yeah we said that yeah we said
that but in motion do you think she's
like okay at first i thought her teeth
were just really really big but no
excuse maybe i'm tripping i don't know
i think
uh characteristics on a woman's face to
stick out to you so much like just this
one random little thing she's like she
was like like she's beautiful if you
looked at like carter trudeau picture
she's i trust you guys yes trudeau is
also just a beautiful man
let's see memories the ones where you
transcended the protocol where okay
right there would cuba be one just
pretty eyes
[Music]
let's yeah about some of the people that
you had
your paths crossed with for example
she had sex with fidel castro that's
what this is like proving uh just
showing what watching insinuating
[Music]
[Laughter]
she's gorgeous
[Music]
[Laughter]
dude he looks like
that's kind of crazy that's actually
so is that his dad
no he does uh
his dad was
some really high government official
in canada as well uh but does he look
more like his dad or like fidel castro
i've heard that his dad also looks like
fidel castro
oh god meatball saying is that uh sorry
castro in the middle uh uh
right that's what i'm assuming yeah i
think that's what they're doing yeah
from the setup okay then or maybe that's
his maybe that's yeah is this
that's true
castro and then who oh nevermind
[Music]
damn he's just so fast with the edits
look at how like he's holding he's just
like holding on to his feet
holding on to his style
[Music]
you know why he's in power he has got
charisma coming out his ears what a
charm
whoa
[Laughter]
whoa yeah so that's at crack connoisseur
just uh that's a great edit just
incredible it was great
uh video two is another one it's a
little it's a little bit more uh
abrasive but it's basically showing the
hypocrisy
of uh
kind of
democrats when it comes to accusing
others of racism um go with us
sorry
it's all good
easy money
oh yeah that's pusha t
[Music]
it's about to be a surgical summer kids
that are called super chop the tops off
the coolers
the spider joint
billy crystal and blackface just give me
your blood
music snakes right
[Music]
oh forgot he was on csi watch the body
silverman blackface
who's
drake can do blackface
he was he said he was doing blackface
for like an art project he's working
with a friend on drake that was the
photo picture he used for oh yeah
but he's black so can he do blackface or
no i don't know if people are saying
he's like it's wrong it's like it's the
fact that he has that photo up and out
of context it looks really bad but when
he was explaining it
i was doing it for an art project to
like show something else but like even
if like he even him having it up there
uh uh up there out of context
people shouldn't really care because he
is black so he should be able to do that
it was just a it was just a battle move
on pusha t's part that's all yeah cause
like that's like me just painting my
face even wider and then people having a
problem with it he's essentially
he's calling him an uncle tom yeah and
he got him he got people to listen he
got people to [ __ ]
talk about it you know i'm not upset
about it i think it's just a battle move
on push the t's part but like i think
majority of the people don't really care
but it got people talking okay that's
all it did
so yeah at crack connoisseur is just a
provocative provocative conspiratorial
edits set to hip hop music and uh yeah i
always always think that is interesting
when you do find someone that [ __ ] uh
is so adamant about like
racism being evil and all this stuff but
then like you go back and find these
things where
they've done some like
[ __ ] to where you're like oh [ __ ] that's
a jimmy kimmel is the perfect example of
that like i mean he he's just very like
ready to point the finger at people but
he's done blackface which like
i don't like him dressing up as carl
malone like i like i don't know many
people could say they don't have a
problem with it but the fact the way he
reacts to other people doing a similar
thing is what makes it's the hypocrisy
that the hypocrisy yeah got it that's
yeah
yeah
it's just interesting you know yeah
because i'm like
yeah howard stern too is just yeah
howard
he he has crazy sketches where he's like
again there's there's blackface where
you dress as a black person then there's
minstrelsy where you do the white lips
and you're like dancing on stage because
that was yeah that was like the
depiction of like how black people
supposedly looked back in the day
was this it nick yeah
that just looks weird that's just weird
he was also like i mean with that i
think there's like some context that
because if he's doing something with
sherman hemsley yeah that's the thing i
think the approval is from sherman
hensley it's like dan aykroyd in uh
trading places with andy murphy when
they uh he was acting like as a jamaican
i don't know there's just like uh
it's context matters it's one more
interesting yeah i think yeah i think
context is very very very very very very
very very very very [ __ ] important
context and intent
context and intent
it's very very very [ __ ] important
and i feel like a lot of times people
want to forget about it and they want to
[ __ ] lash out on some [ __ ] because
like trading places is actually one of
my [ __ ] top favorite movies
i love that [ __ ] movie and you know i
i think again like it's
i agree with you that context matters in
like every single situation you gotta
look at what happened but then it's like
how hypocritical howard is i'm with nick
on this too yeah when it happens to
someone else he doesn't he will not he
he would ask that you need to look at
context
all the time i mean just in
howard howard i don't actually don't
worry i actually don't know much about
howard stern other than what from my
from what i hear from uh
brian
but i don't know i never watch the shows
or anything like that i don't know what
are their
opinions on him i think he used to be
super cool and now he just sucks because
he likes saddled i think they're pretty
much in the same area yeah yeah i mean
it is just he would always get in
trouble for being on pc and now he is
turned into like the most you know what
it reminds me he's still a great
interview you know what that is all
right howard stern is the man and
invented broadcasting you know what that
energy reminds me of it's like the
born-again christian that used to be bad
as [ __ ] and then now that they're good
they're they're like judging all the
people for the things that they [ __ ]
did that's what that like energy reminds
me of similar yeah yeah it's like it's
like [ __ ] you know where you used to be
yeah it's like yeah so check out crack
connoisseur check out
yeah those are pretty funny videos i
like it he's got so many that like make
you think and i'm like have to like that
first that fidel castro one someone that
i follow retweeted it and they're like
they said it makes me laugh every time
and like the first half i'm watching i'm
like what is this even trying to say
like what what do i not know but then he
starts to make it clear towards the end
yeah it's so fast he goes rapid fire i i
respect the edit see i i can't get into
that stuff because i'm like oh my damn
my brain gotta think that what yeah
that quick i'm like i can't do it
i was like whatever whatever if you ask
what y'all say then that's what it is
that's how i feel about like a lot of
[ __ ] you're like an old man in that
regard where it's like oh yeah
yeah
all right
all right
change my mind okay
i don't know i can't [ __ ]
it's just i know i think about other
[ __ ] that is like important to me yeah
that like i don't know helps my [ __ ]
brain and that wouldn't that would not
help that would not [ __ ] help my
brain there's other ones that i think
they help your brain i don't know really
that one's so aggressive because it says
the n-word right away yeah
uh but there's other ones that are just
like
i don't know you just give it a scroll
give it a go i'll link i'll link yeah
i'll link you okay
make it make it the transition to check
it out easy i'm telling you they'll
don't
make you think see the world of stoicism
has got me [ __ ] up to where i i don't
pay attention to much things of that
nature you know what would help you pay
attention though
magic mind
impressive impressive whoa
without even taking it she remember this
is what
those are the long term effects
thank you it's a long term
i'm playing chappelle's throat
the [ __ ] was that
impressive that's the long-term effects
of magic mind it helps your memory yep
now i got now i gotta go to [ __ ] i
have to take it every single time or
that's withdrawals we don't know
i said or it's worth
two honestly i think the ones we've been
drinking that had all the sediment when
we opened it i think those are fairly
old yeah but i wasn't going to help
that's why
this one
i don't think they get old
it's not that they expired it's like
it's like they were sitting or if you
have a juice that's been sitting for a
while and it just like separates but you
shake it up and it's just as good as
this i'm soju mm-hmm some soju soldier's
alcohol so it's a little different
oh wait but there's
you boy
dude that's a great name soju boy
look at how long does magic seven oh
that's how many days you have to drink
it oh
what to get the full effects you can
feel that no
you i think the word you're looking for
is expire
oh did you type that in oh he did it oh
look at that man all right people
it's a very common thing yeah you said
you dropped out of uh santa monica
community college i didn't know did you
even go to college yep
whoa
is the fight
expression alone you watch the video
where i competed at college nationals oh
that show yeah
that's true fair enough see in
christian's head have you seen that
movie uh
the what was the baseball movie where
like it was bad news beers
the other one what basketball no uh
basically all the dreams where it was um
what's his name from the european gigolo
um
yes there we go bench warmers and
there's that kid who was like i am 18.
rob schneider
do you remember that guy like cuban guys
i don't think i've ever seen it oh just
aware of it there's a scene where like
this grown ass man comes in to play
baseball and they're like oh he's 12.
like i'm gonna see some id he shows the
ref the id photo and it's like 20 saying
i am 12. that's what i think christian
thinks of chappelle's like was it this
one yeah whole cheerleading career yeah
like it's fake
no i just i thought it was in high
school for some reason i don't i didn't
think college got your high school in
college yeah but i felt like i'm saying
like i thought like the national [ __ ] i
thought that was in high school not oh
no that was college yeah benchmarks was
a good movie great movie anyways cheer
guys i don't think nick schwartzen would
be in anything not funny he's so true
even the shitty movies he's in like he's
he's so [ __ ] like the one he did
where he was the porn star with the tiny
dick what
i forgot what it was called it's like a
older movie where he was playing like
this guy with a micro penis but he does
porn
and it was hilarious he became this like
giant point
star from it yeah
it's a constantly evolving formula uh
they put different amounts of honey in
it and also
a really important thing to know about
magic mine this once daily elixir it's
the anti-procrastination drink but uh
the important thing about uh where magic
mine sources its matcha from
is that
there's four different see i didn't
screenshot it
but there's four different seasons of
matcha uh and we're in like prime season
right now so they're really
a ton of ton of [ __ ] matcha right now
so go to magic mind dot co slash dark
he's from above dart
wait 30 off and quit procrastinating
change your life yeah yeah dark the
movie is called bucky larson born to be
a star it was released in 2011. damn
that was a good movie yeah you dive in
deep cut deep cut
oh he was in the goldbergs
do you think he ever worked with did he
work with calendar on the goldbergs or
no they're buddies
that's probably how he got the job
um
i haven't seen
oh is that a special no what is this
he does have one of the funniest
specials
around one uh show filmed in like 2 000
[ __ ] see you see who farted yes
dude that that special
i i we looking for
good [ __ ]
that particular
hour uh we i listened to
senior year of college when we drove
back from panama city beach in a car
with five dudes everybody was like
hungover and miserable and we put that
on and we were all in [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] hilarious oh my god he's the
best that's a good special to watch if
you haven't watched he has a he has a
bit
where he's like
was it a monkey no that said it too but
uh he he used to get drunk and go to
bars and he'd pull out his dick and he
pulled over his wrist and he'd walk up
to people who'd be like you know what
time time
and he walked up to one girl and she was
like that's hilarious let me show my
boyfriend
that he
he's like okay and she's like look at
this he's like dude do you know what
time it is and the guy goes
is that your [ __ ] dick
and he throws him out of the bar oh man
the way he yells it
because he just will change he'll zero
to 100 he's screaming
he's great oh yeah he he's from
minneapolis
and i worked at acme comedy club and
like he would just decide before he goes
on tour that he's going to do like three
nights there and so like i i would buy
pack i worked there but i would buy
tickets
to go to his shows and yeah he's i mean
pack the [ __ ] out yeah yeah acme is 300
people yeah everybody was like half the
people knew him like yeah yeah he's the
man i can't wait to get to that level
where i'm like [ __ ]
selling strong tickets
i think i'll get there soon i don't know
i think i know i will you know oh well
strong
i did pretty good i didn't do too bad
when i was in salt lake city where are
you next
san diego san diego i better [ __ ]
kill it i think we have a lot of fans
out there
uh san diego may sixth and seventh
i'll be out there there's this new
comedy club i'm actually doing the
opening weekend of this comedy club
which is big uh it's called mic drop
comedy club and then phoenix if i don't
sell out phoenix as a one-nighter
on may 12th
i'll [ __ ] kick somebody in the dick
and i i mean that do you know who uh
meatball okay
i'll kick him with a dick that's gonna
make people not buy i know yeah
i don't know uh
who's someone everybody likes
okay justin
yeah i tried to say justin bieber but i
don't think i ever get that close to him
yeah that's right yeah no may 12th and
then i forgot april april 20th through
the 23rd i'll be in uh
austin texas doing a moon tower comedy
festival doing a bunch of shows around
the city so
go on their website and just search my
name and then you'll see where i'm
performing and stuff so what do you
recommend this week
i recommend
i feel like we've been going for almost
two hours i don't know yeah i recommend
hour fourteen
uh
yeah what the [ __ ] do i recommend
what have you been doing recently i know
right i feel like you do the same thing
i literally feel like you do the same
thing yeah yeah
and he's like boring [ __ ] human ever
any trails you would recommend oh
i was about to say a hike but i just
realized i said it last week uh okay uh
food you want us to come back
yeah come back to me come back to me
oh i already said mine mm-hmm
oh [ __ ]
gotcha who's turning my turn name it
again uh weird history on youtube oh
yeah
um what was i gonna say
oh so for instagram the daily stoke
which i'm sure you guys already follow
daily stoic they just always
ryan holiday puts like quotes from
philosophers back in the day it's really
powerful and also um
what got me back into fishing
was a youtube video called our youtube
channel called fisherman's life and also
ace videos so
it actually made my life so much happier
you want to know one of my favorite
quotes what's up off of daily stoic
it's from marcus aurelius
um
be tolerant of others and strict on
yourself
i like that very good right so many good
quotes dude oh that one that one's like
[ __ ] bible to me yeah
you're tolerant of others and strict on
yourself i was like yep oh that's a good
one too we suffer more in imagination
yeah that's a power that's so powerful i
love this one how [ __ ] beautiful is
that oh my gosh
i love that i know shout out to seneca
also it's chin's birthday guys oh [ __ ]
oh yeah well yeah sort of i didn't know
that yeah
his birthday is on the 17th so i'm
guessing when this comes out or were you
gonna have two days after happy birthday
i finally caught one birthday i was like
kind of slick the way he caught it too
wait wait are these coming out on
sundays or fridays now
it's just
i really want to come out on fridays
and nightly i think tomorrow morning
like i'll have time to that's like when
i plan on editing it nice i don't like
yeah i just it's fridays it's fridays so
shooting for fridays but every now and
then it'll be a sunday hey it's all okay
it comes out when it comes out you guys
you guys watch sundays
so whenever it comes out watch it wish
chin a happy birthday in the comments
and that be that i'm a b testing release
times yeah
podcast chappelle's world yeah great
podcast yeah
white mike everybody's talking about
having white mike back on here for sure
she's got two episodes yeah i did two
episodes with my white mike uh one's
already out already on thick boy um the
dick boy youtube channel all audio
platforms audio platforms yeah just
support my podcast i really love doing
that podcast and the more the merrier
always and uh yeah i like talking about
fun music [ __ ] so yeah there's more to
my life than just being a
you know a funny guy
and if you do watch chappelle's world
part two with mike white with white mike
jesus chops
drops tomorrow at 3 p.m yeah there you
go well or it'll already be out oh yeah
it would have already been out so
nevermind thursday's 3 p.m there you go
there we go
i don't like how quiet it just got all
right
okay those are our recommendations nick
was supposed to go next yeah
yeah i love how proud he just said that
with a giant smile
um
it was good
30 minutes whatever
trying to think uh
sky path first of all yeah
recommendation by your sky tokens while
they're so cheap um
he's trying to help the world become a
safer place uh
for other recommendations um
there's this i mean i watched it a while
ago i believe it's this german show uh
it's called dark it is probably one of
the perfect
what cast after dark oh oh [ __ ] i need
to put two and two together
um but yeah it's probably one of the
best shows i've ever seen and i kind of
regret finishing it because i want to
rewatch it so i highly recommend it
there we go there we go all right thank
you guys for tuning in this week and
every week and all of the above and
we'll see you [ __ ] next time okay bye
so
[Music]
[Music]
you